[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel a par la voix
de son président monsieur léon noël
donné les résultats officiels du
référendum
[Applaudissements]
ce scrutin clôture est une phase de la
vème république et le général de gaulle
a accepté la démission du premier
ministre le président de la république
l'a chaudement remercié de ses efforts
et de son dévouement pendant les trois
ans en mois et 6 jours de son
gouvernement et l'on a vu à michel debré
détendus et souriants
quelques heures plus tard le général de
gaulle nommé au poste de premier
ministre
monsieur georges pompidou le nouveau
chef du gouvernement s'est immédiatement
mis en devoir de former un ministère qui
comprenait au moins deux techniciens et
davantage de politiques
et à l'hôtel matignon entre messieurs
michel debré et georges pompidou s'est
déroulée dans une cordiale atmosphère la
transmission des pouvoirs un chapitre
nouveau va s'ouvrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jugement de l'ex général jours
sera-t-il le dramatique épisode qui
pleurera une période féconde en
événements dramatiques la crise
algérienne on a pu mettre des noms sur
les visages des protagonistes de ce
douloureux procès le député algérien
robert abdessalam l'ex directeur de
l'écho d'alger monsieur alain de série
ni un membre du tribunal monsieur
pasteur d'algérie raddho le général
allard
madame albert camus madame jouer petite
ombre perdu dans l'ombre des couloirs
enfin le président barney qui dirigeait
les débats
m
sortant de la voiture cellulaire qui
l'amenait de la santé l'ex général
jouhaud qu'attendait au terme de trois
journées de dramatique péripéties la
condamnation à mort
a alger la série des plasticages a
continué au compte de l'organisation de
l'armée secrète on devait notamment
porter l'explosion qui a rendu
inutilisable
la tour de contrôle de l'aéroport de
maison blanche
[Applaudissements]
le trafic aérien toutefois prise en
charge par les services de guidage
militaire n'a pas été interrompue
[Musique]
la pointe de l'île de la cité à l'ombre
de notre dame une crypte garde désormais
le souvenir de deux cent mille français
morts en déportation
le général de gaulle en présence de
monsieur michel debré et de nombreuses
personnalités a inauguré cette tombe
symbolique les deux cent mille martyrs
de l'exil
en se recueillant devant le déporter
inconnu c'est le tribut de la nation qui
a porté le général de gaulle à ceux qui
sont obscures et man noir pour elle dans
la détresse des camps et dont la
destinée s'inscrit dans cette devise
désespéré il allait à l'autre bout de la
terre et ils ne sont pas revenus
[Musique]
saint sébastien a subi les assauts de la
galère ce vent d'ouest nord ouest des
côtes atlantiques et le spectacle qui ne
manquait pas de grandeur auraient été
perdus si une caméra n'avait pas été là
lancée à la poursuite des rares voitures
qui s'était aventuré sur le paseo nuevo
les vagues déchaînées poussèrent leurs
assauts jusqu'à l'intérieur de la ville
il en faut davantage bien sûr pour qu'on
se trouve la saint sébastien mais tout
de même on ne voit pas cela tous les
jours
[Musique]
c'était simple il fallait y penser un
miroir parapluie concentrent les rayons
solaires sur une sphère laquelle libère
des vapeurs de mercure qui alimente une
turbine et l'énergie solaires assurent à
deux minuscules réacteur une poussée de
20 grammes moyennant quoi feuilleton le
futur satellite français placés sur une
première orbite pour à lui-même sans
choisir une autre
en attendant la construction de la fusée
qui le lancera fait on a tout de même
voyagé il fera les beaux jours de
l'exposition de hanovre simple débuts
[Musique]
au camp de satory un autre engin
d'avenir a été révélée à la curiosité le
véhicule français à effet de sol comme
disent les techniciens c'est à dire
capable de se mouvoir sur un coussinet
d'air comprimé et ce n'est pas une mince
révolution quand il songe nous vivons
depuis des millénaires sur une invention
de génie l'un rouge et voici qu'on nous
propose une civilisation sans roues
[Musique]
un conducteur d'un deux-roues à moteur
dit la sagesse des nations est sur la
route un élément parfois dangereux mais
toujours sans défense c'est être sujet à
toutes les chutes ne se protéger même
pas la tête
la loi doit d'y mettre bon ordre
aujourd'hui le casque est obligatoire
mais tout de même pour n'importe quel
casque
[Musique]
pas celui ci dont la pointe paratonnerre
et peu convaincante
enfin celui-ci non plus un peu trop
décoratifs pour l'époque que nous vivons
quant à ce dernier en dépit des
garanties nov il semble quand même un
peu dépassé non le casque obligatoire
est un casque étudié uniquement pour les
chocs à la tête apte à protéger selon
les normes les plus protectrices la
boîte crânienne de son possesseur
à preuve les essais de résistance de
tout ordre imposé à ses coiffures auquel
tout médiocrité est absolument interdit
[Musique]
un casque établi en vue de la protection
doit absolument protéger reste que de
mauvais esprit parleront d'élégance
méconnu de dignité méprisés arrêtons les
du prince philippe à la reine
d'angleterre et au président de la
république que de nobles front n'ont pas
craint de porter ce qu'on peut à juste
titre appelé ici un couvre chef
et puis quelle sécurité et même en
dehors des dangers de la route
est ce que le casque de motocycliste ne
deviendrait pas avec facilité tout
simplement la coiffure d'extérieur
[Musique]
et
même d'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est dans un palais des sports archi
comble à bruxelles que pierre kosmin se
met en jeu son titre de champion
d'europe des poids coq devant l'italien
piero rôle sûr de lui le boxeur belge
culotte blanche attaque d'entrée sans
laisser à son adversaire le temps de
souffler ces deux boxeurs sont rapides
et mordant comme s'il avait encore 20
ans et pourtant ils ont dépassé tous de
la trentaine cos mince à 31 ans rouleau
35 ans il est vrai que dans cette
catégorie les boxeurs sont ordinairement
très agressif quel que soit leur âge et
puis les choses se gâtent rôle on trouve
l'ouverture un crochet du gauche
fulgurant au creux de l'estomac sayo
cosmos n'est plus champion d'europe il a
fallu un peu plus de 12 minutes pour en
arriver là c'est un moment terrible pour
un boxeur il a mal il ne peut plus rien
d'autre que de pleurer ses illusions
perdues
pour renault c'est le triomphe et c'est
alphonse halimi qui lui remet sa
ceinture de champion d'europe
[Applaudissements]
les rugbymen français en maillot clair
on jouer à quitte ou double contre
l'irlande dans le tournoi des six
nations la chance aidant ils ont
parfaitement tenu leur pari dès le début
du match et c'est demont déjà transformé
par albaladejo après quelques minutes de
jeu 5 à 0
et puis tout s'est arrêté là on n'est
pas sorti de la grisaille pendant de
très longs moments on a beaucoup couru
de part et d'autre sans soulever
l'enthousiasmé des 40000 spectateurs de
colombes fort heureusement les irlandais
n'ont pas baissé les bras ils ont même
donné un peu de piment à la rencontre en
jouant avec beaucoup d'application
et ce n'est qu'en fin de partie que les
français se sont décidés vraiment à
montrer ce qu'ils avaient fait
cette attaque qui amène le deuxième
essai à venir
le festival offensif de la france se
poursuit mais on regrette qu'il ait
fallu attendre le dernier quart d'heure
pour assister à des actions
spectaculaires finalement 11 à 0 pour
les français et la victoire dans le
tournoi des six nations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]